é bem
eu queria ficar muito feliz se eu saísse
daqui se a vocês levassem com vocês duas
peças do meu quebra cabeça
a sema não só por isso que se tem duas
peças do quebra cabeça que eu quero que
vocês levem com vocês que se fizer isso
valeu todo todo o trabalho
a primeira é uma frase que diz que a
carreira é como uma viagem sem destino
você sabe onde começa mas você nunca
sabe onde vai acabar
isso é verdade é verdade mesmo então
essa é uma peça do quebra-cabeça que não
serviu pra mim eu não acreditei nisso
também não isso não pra mim pra mim não
é assim
eu sabia exatamente como é que essa
minha carreira eu sabia exatamente como
é que é ser a minha vida profissional eu
seria um designer de automóveis era isso
conhece desde piazinho eu ia ser de sabe
que há seis anos e antônia não só isso
eu sabia que ia ser tão famoso quanto
pininfarina de o diário bertone meu
escritório é na itália é claro eu ia
morar lá também na beira de um lago
bacana eu tinha o logotipo da minha
empresa tal isso não é fácil
isso pronto e começou muito bem minha
vida eu desenhava muito bem e logo que
entrei na faculdade eu é que comecei a
trabalhar com automóveis estão fui
conseguir emprego em uma empresa que
fazia carros esportivos levei lá meus
desenhos e os caras iam na as abelhas
para desenho muito bem que legal vamos
trabalhar com ele e cara trabalhei muito
comecei trabalhando com carros
esportivos da eu fiz um bug é uma mini
van e um carro para a família e
começamos a trabalhar com o carro de
corrida
decorrida era muito legal ea minha vida
de designer era fica no escritório
trabalhando no estúdio e tal
está um negócio e levar pra pista e é
toda a galera equipe pra pista testava e
tal
a sacada ninguém quer uma vida dessa só
que me pagava muito mal nos lógico é
feliz da vida moleque assim mas pagava
mon e o que eu queria mesmo era
trabalhar numa grande empresa automotiva
que ela ia ser meu espaço então queria
trabalhar na ford que trabalhar gm
também a fox vague pelo empregão ali
legal e peguei a minha meus desenhos seu
currículo e foi para essas empresas né
cara de alguma coisa de errado ali algo
aconteceu e que aconteceu foi a primeira
das grandes crises que o brasil
enfrentou e talvez a mais séria é o
brasil concentrou em de vôo ou seja o
brasil não tinha adianta pagar suas
contas
não tinha dinheiro pra comprar petróleo
não tinha dinheiro para importar
gasolina
então nossa indústria automotiva levava
gente assim mandar gente embora aos
montes
imagina eu lá na porta da ford o meu
desenho ea galera sendo mandado embora
né cara e aí eu descobri o segundo a
peça do quebra-cabeça que vocês têm que
levar pra vocês
essa frase aqui o pior que pode
acontecer em uma viagem é dar tudo certo
essa frase eu tirei um livro precisamos
falar com kevin precisamos falar sobre
kevin iê é a mãe do keve e ela é ela
coloca muito bem que quando uma viagem
não dá certo é quando você conhece mais
você mesmo é quando você perde o trem
que você vai descobrir um outro caminho
chegando você precisa quer quando você
não tem mais o hotel vai achar um lugar
para morar algum lutador em algum lugar
você vai conhecer gente só vai conhecer
de você vai se desafiar isso cara isso é
muito legal é aí que você cresce e é o
que eu tinha para fazer então eu comecei
a ser um designer de tudo eu falei por
sua beleza não é só os caras pra lá e
vão começar a trabalhar com tudo
e de fato comecei a entrar na no mundo
do design e comecei a desenhar coisas né
z primeira empresa que eu fui trabalhar
numa fábrica de pincéis imagina velha
sair de interlagos então olha o exemplo
em céu cria um risco aquilo tudo bem
tudo bem tudo tem um começo
e aí nessa fábrica de pincel eu comecei
a ver que porque eu desenhava era muito
valorizado pessoal dizendo olha só como
escada desenhar bem olha que legal tal
erro meu emprego emprego emprego era
reconhecido e valorizado ganhava bem e é
a que dá alguma coisa aconteceu aqui mas
também ganhava bem ea hora que eu que eu
entendi que a aaa eu desenhava bem
estava indo muito bem eu percebi um
negócio e começa uma jornada legal que
desenhar bem não era suficiente
muita gente tinha que ter um diferencial
as pessoas na verdade não queriam alguém
que desenhasse meio mas queria alguém
que surpreendesse alguém que precisa que
que gerasse uma surpresa que uma
originalidade uma criatividade então eu
aprendi que a partir de desenhar bem
você tinha que ser surpreender e e isso
eu fiz muito bem eo time olha o eu fazia
cada apresentação que hoje eu vejo como
era bom e adorava fazer isso
as apresentações eram diferentes o
cenário era diferente tudo era diferente
ea diretoria da empresa adorava ver nas
apresentações nossa vamos lá ver aquele
cara que faz coisa legal tal e e ali eu
vi que portanto não bastava só desenhar
e surpreender se tinha que executar a
parada tinha que executar ea executar
exigiam outras competências
essas competências faziam com que eu
precisasse ser mais que cria a
metodologia criar processo que estava me
organizar
então era eram uma outra coisa que
aconteceu eo que me organizei e tive
toda essa
essa cadeia construída sem aconteceu
referiu o executivo de design e quando
você vira um executivo de design
você passa a lidar com pessoas você não
vai mais trabalhar com design só
trabalhar com pessoas que são o que você
vai ter que fazer é que a tua equipe vai
ter que desenhar bem vai ter que ser
surpreendente vão ter que ser
provocativos você vai ter que fazer
esses caras executarem bem o que estão
fazendo você vai ter que fazer eles
serem organizados metodológicos porque
lidar com pessoas é um é uma competência
que eu aprendi e gostei muito de fazer
cara eu adorava se lidar com conflitos
a dra adorava gerenciar diferenças e
eles não sei se sabe mas designer é um
bicho difícil né
são as estrelas assim todo mundo autor
alto não é em lidar com isso não era
fácil mas era muito legal porque você
tinha que gerar a expectativa dessa
galera sempre fazer isso de fato se
transformar em um valor seguindo se esse
trajeto
eu comecei a observar também de novo
gente vai chegar lá onde eu quero chegar
o design ele era o que alimentava algo
que estava acontecendo muito fortemente
nos últimos anos que é inovação
corporativa
não sei se sabe ou é o acompanho isso
mas inovação corporativa e inovação
passou a ser a palavra da vez né
todo mundo quer fazer renovação então já
têm curso inovação é tudo sobre inovação
ea inovação na verdade é baseado por um
pensamento do design
então eu conectei o design a esse modelo
de inovação corporativa que fazia com
que as empresas tivessem resultados
diferentes a partir de um pensamento
único que parte do design e o público a
estátua foi um passo pequeno porque
quando você trabalha com inovação
corporativa
você consegue reproduzir sua startup eu
me tornei então
mentor de startup hoje eu sou investidor
de startup sou mentor de startup
trabalho nesse ecossistema só tem um
lance assim a tudo isso que eu tô
falando eu eu posso dizer com muita
certeza que ao longo da minha carreira
eu conheci muita gente que desenhava
muito melhor que o que era muito mais
criativo que o que sabia fazer gestão de
de projetos o dia de pessoas muito
melhor que o time confirme diferencial
eu acho que eu descobri isso já tem mais
velho era ter senso de oportunidade
era era conseguir ter a a percepção dos
lugares que precisavam ser ocupados e
usar o meu conhecimento e o meu
potencial minha força de trabalho
preocupar esses lugares e senso de
oportunidade
ele costuma ser conflitante com aquilo
que a gente aprendeu sempre é assim
cara você começa na sua carreira olhas
tem que ter foco tem que ter
perseverança senso de oportunidade às
vezes conflito com isso porque porque se
você tiver foco em um assunto se você
tiver for perseverante em um objetivo
você vai perder uma oportunidade de tudo
o que está acontecendo em torno de você
você não vai ser plástico suficiente
para poder aproveitar tudo aquilo que
está acontecendo em torno de você e é o
senso de oportunidade na verdade que vai
fazer com que você atinja não o sucesso
na sua carreira profissional mas suas
causas pessoais que na verdade são muito
mais importantes do que a opção do que
trazer uma confusão dos diabos que a
você a causa pessoal na internet é muito
mais importante carreira profissional
porque aquilo que você acredita aquilo
que você constrói é aquele que você faz
com o teu coração e e e garcia acredita
é ninguém hoje consegue trabalhar assim
sem sentença
absoluta passe cidade porque o mundo ele
ele está mudando tanto tão rapidamente a
gente acompanha isso ou não acompanhamos
mais essa mudança então fica impossível
se dizia olha quero sair daqui eu quero
chegar lá daqui a 15 anos
daqui a 15 anos ou 10 gente não sabe se
o mundo vai estar aqui se vai ser melhor
ou se vai ser pior
então a gente tem que aproveitar muito
isso que está acontecendo agora e
trabalhar esse momento de uma forma
plena
acreditando que são as suas causas as
suas crenças dos seus valores que vão
fazer você ter sucesso no fim eu trouxe
alguns exemplos muito mais legais que os
meus para falar sobre senso de
oportunidade por exemplo o esteve j
sem saber ele começou a trabalhar com o
computador fazendo um computador e ele
passou pela por telecomunicações fazendo
o iphone chegou no itunes que é um é o
que se conhece o itunes é um é o modelo
de entretenimento de música de vídeo de
games que saiu de das oportunidades que
ele foi encontrando ao longo da vida
dele ele não teve um objetivo o que ele
perseguiu foram causas pessoais foram
crenças pessoais se a gente pegar o
richard branson que eu era o dono é o
dono da da corporação verde
ele começou fazendo uma revista e eles
estudantes ea partir dessa revista ele
ele começou a encontrar oportunidades a
se conectar com os jovens e montou a
virgin records que foi na época dele a
maior gravadora do mundo que tinha os
melhores artistas e uma coisa engraçada
é que num certo momento da ram na
verdade foi no dia da mentira ele soltou
uma mentira falta falsa um fake news
dizendo que ele estava criando blue box
que era uma grande caixa de de com
milhões de músicas e que seriam
conectadas as casas são os usuários
através de fios de cabos steve jobs hoje
e foi o que inspirou a fazer o itunes
então acho que se conectam ele brincou
uma vez com ele dizendo pra você que me
inspirou a fazer o itunes
bom o braço fez ainda foi para
aprendermos e da aviação tem hoje uma
das suas duas maiores companhias de
transporte aéreo até em bancos tudo
porque porque segundo ele - disse que
esteve no brasil recentemente uma
palestra dizendo eu fui aproveitando
oportunidades eu via onde falhavam
serviço onde podia ser melhor
era ali que eu queria atender melhor o
consumidor e um nome que está muito mais
perto de vocês todos hoje é do ela ela
mas que ele começou como um desenhista
de videogame o primeiro videogame ele
vendeu aos 12 e 15 anos
além de um videogame ea partir daí ele
foi pro tesla e hoje ele é o dono da
spacex que faz foguetes que é um
fornecedor da nasa de novo aproveitando
oportunidades aproveitando competências
o que eu quero dizer com isso tudo eu
acho que essa talvez seja a principal
mensagem que eu tenho é que mesmo nós
simples mortais não são steve jobs não
era um romance pra pra aproveitar ver o
que está do lado perceber que têm nossas
antenas nossos radares ligados sempre as
oportunidades que estão próximas da
gente que nem a gente pode ter certeza
que não importa onde a nossa viagem vai
chegar vai ser um lugar muito legal e
que vai nos fazer aquilo que a gente
mais busca com certeza que a felicidade
só valeu obrigado pelo tempo